El título es: "Más raro de lo que podemos suponer: La extrañeza de la ciencia."
"Más raro de lo que podemos suponer" proviene de J.B.S. Haldane,
el famoso biólogo, quien dijo, "Mi sospecha personal es que
el universo no sólo es más raro de lo que suponemos,
sino más raro de lo que podemos suponer.
Sospecho que hay más cosas en el cielo y la tierra
de las que son, o pueden ser soñadas en cualquier filosofía."
Richard Feyman comparó la precisión de las teorías cuánticas --
sus predicciones experimentales -- con especificar el ancho de Norteamérica
con la precisión del grosor de un cabello.
Esto significa que la teoría cuántica tiene que ser en cierto sentido verdadera.
Pero las presunciones que la teoría cuántica necesita hacer
para realizar tales predicciones son tan misteriosas
que el mismo Feynman debió señalar,
"Si crees que comprendes la teoría cuántica,
no entiendes la teoría cuántica."
Es tan rara que los físicos recurren a una u otra
interpretación paradójica de ella.
David Deutsch, quien hablará aquí, sobre El Tejido de la Realidad,
adhiere a la interpretación de "mundos múltiples" de la teoría cuántica,
porque lo peor que se puede decir de ella es
que es ridículamente derrochadora.
Postula un vasto y rápidamente creciente número de universos
existiendo en paralelo -- mutuamente indetectables, excepto a través
del estrecho conducto de los experimentos de mecánica cuántica.
Y ese es Richard Feynman.
El biólogo Lewis Wolpert
cree que la rareza de la física moderna
es sólo un ejemplo extremo. La ciencia, al contrario que la tecnología,
hace violencia al sentido común.
Cada vez que bebes un vaso de agua, él señala,
es probable que bebas al menos una molécula
que pasó por la vejiga de Oliver Cromwell. (risas)
Es sólo teoría de probabilidades elemental.
El número de moléculas por vaso es enormemente mayor
que el número de vasos llenos, o vejigas llenas, en el mundo --
y, por supuesto, no hay nada especial en Cromwell
o las vejigas. Acabas de inhalar un átomo de nitrógeno
que pasó por el pulmón derecho del tercer iguanodonte
a la izquierda del árbol Cycadophyta.
"Más raro de lo que podemos suponer."
¿Qué nos hace capaces de suponer algo,
y qué nos dice eso sobre lo que podemos suponer?
¿Hay cosas en nuestro universo que estarán
por siempre más allá de nuestro alcance, pero no para alguna
inteligencia superior? ¿Hay cosas en nuestro universo
que son, en principio, inalcanzables para cualquier mente,
sin importar que tan superior?
La historia de la ciencia ha sido una larga serie
de violentas tormentas mentales, sucesivas generaciones
se enfrentaron con crecientes niveles de rareza
en el universo.
Estamos tan habituados a la idea de que la Tierra gira --
en lugar de que el Sol se mueva por el cielo -- es difícil darnos cuenta
de la devastadora revolución mental que debió ser.
Después de todo, parece obvio que la Tierra es enorme e inmóvil,
y el Sol pequeño y móvil. Pero vale la pena recordar
el comentario de Wittgenstein sobre el tema.
"Dime," le preguntó a un amigo, "¿Por qué siempre se dice que era natural
asumir que el sol se movía alrededor de la tierra
en lugar de que la Tierra estuviera rotando?"
Su amigo replicó, "Bueno, obviamente porque se ve como si
el Sol se moviera alrededor de la Tierra."
Wittgenstein replicó, "Bueno, ¿y cómo se hubiera visto
si se viera como si la Tierra estuviera rotando?" (risas)
La ciencia nos ha enseñado, contra toda intuición,
que las cosas aparentemente sólidas, como cristales y rocas,
están casi enteramente compuestas de espacio vacío.
Y la imagen ilustrativa es el núcleo de un átomo como una mosca
en el medio de un estadio deportivo y el siguiente átomo
está en el siguiente estadio deportivo.
Así que parece que la más sólida, dura y densa roca
en realidad es casi todo espacio vacío, interrumpido por partículas
tan separadas que no deberían contar.
¿Por qué, entonces, las rocas parecen sólidas y duras e impenetrables?
Como biólogo evolucionista diré esto: nuestros cerebros han evolucionado
para ayudarnos a sobrevivir dentro de órdenes de magnitud de tamaño y velocidad
en los que operan nuestros cuerpos. Nunca evolucionamos para navegar
en el mundo de los átomos.
Si así fuera, nuestros cerebros probablemente percibirían las rocas
como llenas de espacio vacío. Las rocas se sienten duras e impenetrables
a nuestras manos precisamente porque objetos como rocas y manos
no pueden penetrar unos a otros. Por tanto es útil
para nuestros cerebros construir nociones como "solidez" e "impenetrabilidad"
porque tales nociones nos ayudan a navegar nuestros cuerpos
por el mundo de tamaño medio en el que tenemos que navegar.
En el otro extremo de la escala, nuestros ancestros nunca tuvieron que
navegar por el cosmos a velocidades cercanas
a la de la luz. Si lo hubieran hecho, nuestros cerebros serían mucho mejores
para entender a Einstein. Quiero dar el nombre de "Mundo Medio"
al ambiente de escala media en el que hemos evolucionado
la habilidad para actuar -- No la "Tierra Media"
Mundo Medio (risas)
Hemos evolucionado como habitantes del Mundo Medio, y eso limita
lo que somos capaces de imaginar. Será intuitivamente fácil
aprehender ideas como, cuando un conejo se mueve a
la velocidad promedia de los objetos del Mundo Medio,
y choca con otro objeto del Mundo Medio, como una roca, se noquea.
Les presento al Mayor General Albert Stubblebine III,
comandante de inteligencia militar en 1983.
Él miraba su pared en Arlington, Virginia, y decidió hacerlo.
Aunque fuera una idea aterradora, iría a la oficina contigua.
Se levantó, y se alejó de su escritorio.
¿De qué consiste en su mayoría el átomo? pensó. Espacio.
Comenzó a caminar. ¿De qué estoy hecho yo, mayormente? Átomos.
Aceleró su paso, casi un trote ahora.
¿De qué está hecha la pared, mayormente? Átomos.
Todo lo que tengo que hacer es cruzar los espacios.
Luego, El General Stubblebine estrelló su nariz contra la pared
de su oficina. Stubblebine, quien comandaba 16,000 soldados,
estaba perplejo por su fracaso para atravesar de la pared.
No dudaba que esta habilidad, un día, sería una herramienta común
en el arsenal militar. ¿Quién provocaría a un ejército
que pudiera hacer eso? Esto es de un artículo de Playboy,
que estuve leyendo el otro día. (risas)
Tengo motivos para pensar que es cierto; estaba leyendo Playboy
porque yo mismo, tenía un artículo allí. (risas)
La intuición humana ,sin asistencia, desarrollada en el Mundo Medio
encuentra difícil creer en Galileo cuando dice
que un objeto pesado y uno ligero, sin contar la fricción del aire,
tocarían el suelo en el mismo instante.
Y eso es porque en el Mundo Medio, la fricción del aire siempre existió.
si hubiéramos evolucionado en el vacío esperaríamos
que toquen el suelo simultáneamente. Si fuéramos bacterias,
constantemente perturbadas por el movimiento termal de las moléculas,
sería diferente,
pero somos muy grandes para notar el movimiento Browniano.
De la misma manera, nuestras vidas están dominadas por la gravedad
pero somos casi inconscientes a la fuerza de tensión superficial.
Un pequeño insecto revertiria estas prioridades.
Steve Grand -- es el de la izquierda,
Douglas Adams está a la derecha -- Steve Grand, en su libro,
"Creación: la Vida y Cómo Hacerla", es positivamente mordaz
sobre nuestra preocupación por la materia misma.
Tenemos esta tendencia a pensar que sólo las cosas sólidas, materiales
son realmente cosas. Las ondas de fluctuación electromagnética
en el vacío parecen irreales.
Los Victorianos pensaban que las ondas debían ser ondas de un medio --
el éter. Pero la materia nos parece reconfortante sólo porque
hemos evolucionado para sobrevivir en el Mundo Medio,
donde la materia es una ficción útil.
Un remolino, para Steve Grand, es una cosa con tanta realidad
como una roca.
En un desierto de Tanzania, a la sombra de un volcán
Ol Donyo Lengai, hay una duna de ceniza volcánica.
Lo hermoso es que se mueve.
Es lo que técnicamente llamamos Barchan, y toda la duna
transita el desierto en dirección oeste
a la velocidad de 17 metros por año.
Mantiene su forma de luna y se mueve en dirección de sus cuernos.
Lo que sucede es que el viento sopla en la arena
sobre la pendiente hasta el otro lado, y luego,
cuando cada grano de arena llega a la cima de la cresta,
cae en cascada al interior de la luna creciente,
y así la duna con forma de cuerno se mueve.
Steve Grand señala que nosotros mismos, somos
más como una onda que una cosa permanente.
Nos invita a los lectores "piensa en una experiencia
de tu niñez -- algo que recuerdes claramente,
algo que puedas ver, sentir, quizás incluso oler,
como si estuvieras allí realmente.
Después de todo, realmente estuviste allí, ¿no?
¿Cómo más lo recordarías?
Pero he aquí la sorpresa: No estuviste allí.
Ni un sólo átomo que está en tu cuerpo hoy estuvo allí
cuando eso ocurrió. La materia fluye de un lugar a otro
y momentáneamente se reúne para ser tú.
Lo que sea que eres, por tanto, no eres la materia
de la que estás hecho.
Si eso no te eriza el cabello de la nuca,
léelo de nuevo hasta que lo haga, porque es importante."
Así que "realmente" no es una palabra que debamos usar con confianza
Si un neutrino tuviera cerebro,
que evoluciono en ancestros tamaño neutrino,
diría que las rocas realmente consisten de espacio vacío.
Tenemos cerebros que evolucionaron de ancestros tamaño medio
que no podían atravesar rocas.
"Realmente" para un animal, es lo que su cerebro necesita que sea
para ayudar a su supervivencia,
y debido a que diferentes especies viven en diferentes mundos,
habrá una incómoda variedad de realidades.
Lo que vemos del mundo real no es el mundo desnudo
sino un modelo del mundo, regulado por datos sensoriales,
pero construído para ser útil para enfrentar el mundo real.
La naturaleza del modelo depende del tipo de animal que somos.
Un animal volador necesita un tipo de modelo diferente
de uno andante, trepador o nadador.
Un cerebro de mono debe tener software capaz de simular
un mundo tridimensional de ramas y troncos.
Un software de topo para construír modelos de su mundo
debe adaptarse para uso subterráneo.
Un cerebro de caminador de agua no necesita software 3D,
dado que vive en la superficie de una laguna
en una planilandia de Edwin Abbott.
He especulado que el murciélago ve colores con sus oídos.
El modelo de mundo que un murciélago necesita para navegar
en tres dimensiones atrapando insectos
debe ser muy similar al modelo de mundo de cualquier ave,
un ave diurnal como una golondrina, necesita ejecutar
el mismo tipo de tareas.
El hecho de que el murciélago use ecos en la oscuridad
para ingresar los variables actuales a su modelo,
mientras que la golondrina usa luz, es incidental.
Los murciélagos, sugerí, perciben tonos, como el rojo y el azul,
como etiquetas internas, para algunos aspectos útiles de los ecos --
tal vez la textura acústica de las superficies, velludo o liso y demás,
de la misma manera en que la golondrinas o nosotros usamos
esos tonos percibidos -- rojo o azul, etcétera --
para etiquetar longitudes de onda de luz cortas o largas.
No hay nada inherente en el rojo que lo haga de onda larga.
Y el punto es que la naturaleza del modelo está gobernada por
cómo será usado, más que por la modalidad sensorial involucrada.
J.B.S. Haldane decía algo sobre los animales
cuyo mundo está dominado por el olfato.
Los perros distinguen entre dos ácidos grasos muy similares, muy diluídos:
el ácido caprilico y el ácido caproico.
La única diferencia, es que uno tiene un par extra de
átomos de carbono en la cadena.
Haldane intuyó que un perro probablemente sería capaz de ordenar los ácidos
en el orden de sus pesos moleculares por sus olores,
así como un hombre podría ordenar las cuerdas de un piano
por el orden de sus longitudes oyendo sus notas.
Ahora, hay otro ácido graso, el ácido cáprico,
que es igual a los otros dos,
excepto que tiene dos átomos de carbono más.
Un perro que nunca conoció el ácido cáprico podría, tal vez,
no tener más problemas imaginando su olor del que nosotros tendríamos
imaginando una trompeta, por ejemplo, tocar una nota más aguda
de lo que hemos antes oído.
Tal vez los perros y rinocerontes y otros animales guiados por olfato
huelen en colores. Y el argumento sería
exactamente el mismo que para los murciélagos.
El Mundo Medio -- el rango de tamaños y velocidades
con el que hemos evolucionado para sentirnos intuitivamente cómodos --
es un poco como el estrecho rango del espectro electromagnético
que vemos como luz de varios colores.
Somos ciegos a todas las frecuencias fuera de él,
a menos que usemos instrumentos para ayudarnos.
El Mundo Medio es el estrecho rango de realidad
que juzgamos como normal, al contrario de la rareza
de lo muy pequeño, lo muy grande y lo muy rápido.
Podríamos hacer una escala similar de improbabilidades;
nada es totalmente imposible.
Los milagros son sólo eventos que son extremadamente improbables.
Una estatua de mármol puede agitar su mano saludando; sus átomos,
su estructura cristalina están vibrando de todas maneras.
Debido a que hay tantos de ellos,
y debido a que no hay acuerdo entre ellos
en su dirección preferida de movimiento, el mármol,
que vemos en el Mundo Medio, permanece inmóvil.
Pero los átomos en la mano podrían de repente moverse
de la misma manera al mismo tiempo, una y otra vez.
En ese caso, la mano se movería y la veríamos como si saludara
en el Mundo Medio. La probabilidad esta en contra, claro, es tan improbable
que si comenzaras a escribir zeros en el momento
del origen del universo, aún no habrías
escrito suficientes ceros hoy.
La evolución en el Mundo Medio no nos ha equipado para manejar
eventos muy improbables; no vivimos lo suficiente.
En la inmensidad del espacio astronómico y el tiempo geológico,
eso que parece imposible en el Mundo Medio
podría resultar ser inevitable.
Una manera de pensar esto es contando planetas.
No sabemos cuántos planetas hay en el universo,
pero un buen cálculo es de 10 a la 20 potencia, o 100 trillones
Y eso nos da una buena forma de expresar nuestro calculo
de la improbabilidad de la vida.
Podríamos marcar algunos puntos
a lo largo del espectro de imposibilidades, que se vería como
el espectro electromagnético que acabamos de ver.
Si la vida ha surgido sólo una vez --
Si la vida pudiera originarse una vez por planeta,
podría ser muy común, o podría originarse una vez por estrella,
o una vez por galaxia o tal vez sólo una vez en todo el universo,
en cuyo caso tendría que ser aquí. Y en alguna parte aquí
estaría la posibilidad de que una rana se convierta en príncipe
y cosas mágicas similares.
Si la vida surgió sólo en un planeta en todo el universo,
ese planeta debe ser nuestro planeta, porque estamos aquí hablando de eso.
Y eso significa que si queremos sacar ventaja de ello,
podemos postular eventos químicos en el origen de la vida
lo cual tiene una posibilidad tan baja como uno en 100 trillones.
No creo que tendramos que sacar ventaja de eso,
porque sospecho que la vida es más común en el universo.
Y cuando digo común, aún podría ser tan rara
que ninguna isla de vida jamás encuentre otra,
que es un pensamiento triste.
¿Cómo debemos interpretar "más raro de lo que podemos suponer?"
¿Más raro de lo que en principio podemos suponer,
o sólo más raro de los que podemos suponer, dadas las limitaciones
del aprendizaje evolucionario de nuestro cerebro en el Mundo Medio?
¿Podríamos, por entrenamiento y práctica, emanciparnos
del Mundo Medio y alcanzar una especie de intuición,
así como comprensión matemática de lo muy pequeño
y lo muy grande? Genuinamente no conozco la respuesta.
Me pregunto si podríamos ayudarnos a comprender, digamos,
teoría cuántica, si criamos niños utilizando juegos de computadora,
comenzando en edad temprana, los cuales tengan una especie de
mundo simulado de pelotas atravesando dos rendijas en una pantalla,
un mundo en el que los extraños eventos de la mecánica cuántica
fueran ampliados por la simulación de computadora,
de modo que se vuelvan familiares en la escala del Mundo Medio.
Y, similarmente, un juego de computadora relativista en el que
los objetos en la pantalla manifiesten la Contracción de Lorenz, y así,
para tratar de acostumbrarnos en la manera de pensar --
de llevar a los niños a la manera de pensar en eso.
Quiero terminar aplicando la idea del Mundo Medio
a nuestras percepciones de nosotros mismos.
La mayoría de los científicos hoy suscriben a la visión mecanicista de la mente:
somos como somos porque nuestros cerebros son forzados a ser como son;
nuestras hormonas son como son.
Seríamos diferentes, nuestro carácter sería diferente,
si nuestra neuro-anatomía y nuestra química fisiológica fuera diferente.
Pero los científicos somos inconsistentes. Si fuéramos consistentes,
nuestra respuesta a un mal comportamiento, como un infanticida,
debería ser algo como, esta unidad tiene un componente fallido;
necesita reparación. Eso no es lo que decimos.
Lo que decimos -- e incluyo al más austeramente mecanicista de nosotros,
que probablemente soy yo --
lo que decimos es, "Vil monstruo, la prisión es demasiado buena para ti."
O peor, buscamos venganza, probablemente iniciando
la siguiente fase en una ciclo creciente de contra-venganzas,
lo cual vemos, por supuesto, por todo el mundo hoy.
En breve, cuando pensamos como académicos,
vemos a la gente como máquinas elaboradas y complicadas,
como computadoras o autos, pero cuando volvemos a ser humanos
nos comportamos más como Basil Fawlty, quien, recordemos,
destruyó su auto para enseñarle una lección cuando no arrancó
en la noche de gourmet. (risas)
La razón por la que personificamos las cosas como autos y computadoras
es que así como los monos viven en un mundo arbóreo
y los topos viven en un mundo subterráneo
y los caminantes del agua en una planilandia de tensión superficial,
vivimos en un mundo social. Nadamos en un mar de gente --
una versión social del Mundo Medio.
Evolucionamos para adivinar el comportamiento de otros
volviéndonos brillantes psicólogos intuitivos.
Tratando a las personas como máquinas
puede ser científica y filosóficamente preciso,
pero es una engorrosa pérdida de tiempo
si quieres adivinar lo que hará una persona a continuación.
La manera económicamente útil de pensar en una persona
es tratarla como un agente decidido tras un objetivo
con placeres y dolores, deseos e intenciones
culpa y cargos.
La personificación y la adjudicación de intenciones
es una manera tan exitosa de pensar en los humanos,
que no es sorprendente que el mismo software
a menudo toma control cuando tratamos de pensar en entidades
para las que no es apropiado, como Basil Fawlty con su auto
o como millones de engañados con el universo en conjunto (risas)
Si el universo es más raro de lo que podemos suponer,
¿Es sólo porque fuimos seleccionados naturalmente para suponer
sólo lo que necesitamos suponer para sobrevivir
en el Pleistoceno de África?
¿O son nuestros cerebros tan versátiles y expandibles que podemos
entrenarnos para escapar de la caja de nuestra evolución?
O, finalmente, ¿Hay cosas en el universo tan raras
que ninguna filosofía de cosas, sin importar que tan divinas, podría soñarlas?
Muchas gracias.